honestly i think with the pandemic we
were you know stuck at home with our
kids we had to get more involved in our
education um you know listening to zoom
calls classes things like that it just
parents started realizing wait what is
happening and with the pandemic because
there was so much local control involved
it suddenly became very clear that it
doesn't really matter who the president
is so much for my day-to-day life but it
really matters who my school board who
my governor is american flag upside down
is an old naval
uh symbology and basically it's a
distress signal and our country is
definitely in a state of distress they
are pushing items like critical race
theory and we just want them to educate
rather than indoctrinate i came here to
talk about uh critical race theory and
how it's being used as an emotional
wedge issue
against your equity policy i know you
know
criminal race theory is not taught
as a social worker and parent i
specifically want to express my
gratitude for the board's equity policy
i am excited about the potential of this
equity policy and its ability to address
gaps in our district this policy can
create rich opportunities for staff
development and opportunities for all of
our students to flourish we just
anticipated that our children were going
to school just like we did we're going
to learn reading writing and arithmetic
and everything is going to be fine
they're not facing indoctrination
nobody's talking about their skin color
nobody's talking about their sexual
orientation
but come to find out while we weren't
paying attention it appears that they
are on paper the equity you know the
equity policy on paper looks okay
obviously there are some buzzwords that
have other connotations so you kind of
get into the weeds there but on paper i
think we can all agree that every
student in the district should have an
equal and you know equitable educational
opportunity i completely support that i
recognize that there are some some
issues society-wide that we need to to
address
but i also want them to focus on douglas
county douglas county school board
cannot change the world it's a whole
culture that is being set from the top
from the school board that does not help
any child succeed what it comes down to
for me and i think for so many other
parents is who owns the education and
the moral formation of our kids
is it the parents or is it the state
and it's the parents
and parents need school board members
that will honor that that will partner
with parents and they'll do that in a
way that builds trust
with transparency and accountability i'm
a neighborhood school girl i mean i love
my neighborhood school so this idea that
we're anti-education anti-teacher
anti-public education is literally
insane and it has no bearing in truth
you